les travaux sont presque terminés le
coût des rénovations est passé de 24
millions à 37 millions de dollars
mais ce qui frappe le plus en entrant et
bien c'est la lumière et d immense mur
blanc qui remplace des gradins sombre de
l'ancien vélodrome
je vous souhaite la bienvenue dans un
biotope réinventer un immense salle
d'accueil doublant d'un accès aux
écosystèmes
bien sûr il ya la forêt tropicale avec
ses perroquets ces tortues et ses
poissons
mais ce qui est vraiment nouveau ce sont
ces passerelles qui apporte une nouvelle
perspective
j'étais vraiment surprise mais
agréablement surprise par les
passerelles qui je trouve amène une
vision complètement différente de
l'expérience à ce qu'on voit
l'écosystème dans roues une réplique de
10 mètres de haut de l'écosystème du
golfe du saint laurent avec ses gros
esturgeons et ces macro a aussi été
installée autre nouveauté c'est chaud
corridor de l'âge de 15 mètres et il
fait vraiment froid qui nous mène aux
régions sur antarctique l'expérience
d'un tunnel de glace qui était fabriqué
par les équipes en interne qui est
unique
2 en travaux est tout un défi
architectural jamais je n'aurais pu
croire que la transformation d'un lieu
un bâtiment une place aurait pu autant
nous changer
ouverture donc le 31 août prochain avec
un nombre de visiteurs limité à raison
évidemment de la pandémie
issigeac bissonnet radio canada montréal